let's talk about the creepiness of my
childhood Oh creepy child whoa Sheldon
whoa you that's not what I was talking
about wait we're still talking about
houses right it goes okay good no no the
vampire
Oh the vampire that broke into my house
oh wait I don't know about the aliens
showed oh is that why you wear this
beanie it is all the time conspiracy I
do have a crazy like a really crazy
story for another kid and they were like
ghosts in my house I got we talked about
it a few months ago like the crazy ghost
story but no let's talk about the
horrifying racism yeah Chicago yeah so
check out this image okay yeah just jump
over this image so this is Google and
this is where we're we at we're at 49
West 45th Street and I have no
disrespect for this neighborhood you say
these these houses this is May 2009 so I
grew up on 49th and Laramie in on the
south side of Chicago near Midway
Airport and we were we were always
basically like forbidden from crossing
over north of 47th so earlier today I
was talking to a second Lydia about what
you know we're talking about race
relations and black lives matter and
stuff and I mentioned like you know I
think I talked about this briefly on the
show I did a big Twitter thought about
it okay how 47th Street divided the
races of my area once you went north of
47th it was all black and if you were
south of that it was mostly like poor
white and like Polish immigrant and then
if you went past Cicero to the the east
it was starting it was more Hispanic and
Latino and if you and West you found all
the redneck you know so the street I
grew up on was half Chicago and half
suburb called Stickney okay it's really
funny the streets half done it's malaria
yeah the city would only come in and ply
1/2 the street and so we had a lot of
weird you know racist problems one of
which sidenote the city apparently
banned a low test carts you know that is
is it a little uh like the ice cream
well no it's it's corn quano the corn
with like butter on it or whatever men
man is parmesan and and Redpath spicy
sauce yeah all right and so these little
guys are walking these cars Johnsville
Mexican do
I do love some corn dude hey Lopez was
awesome and so we we'd be hanging at the
park and the little got cart workout
would roll up and without blood yeah
we'd all run out and for a buck you take
a corn on the cob and he cut off the
corn mixing some mayo parmesan and
swirled it up it's amazing it's good one
dollar we'd all eat it I would love one
of those right now apparently the mayor
made it illegal what saying that that
specific business wasn't allowed in this
area because reasons I don't know man
but I'll tell you what I think it is I
think the city wanted the segregation I
do hmm why I don't know I don't know
it's me but they specifically said at
least this is what I was told by locals
in the community okay when they started
sure they felt no when we stopped
showing up I was told specifically about
one of the one of the adults like oh
yeah the mayor said the you know those
street vendors can't come to this area
anymore that's not there okay if you
cross this row they're there and we're
like what but we liked we liked it when
it and then it got replaced by ice cream
trucks so I guess we went from eating
corn eating ice cream but hey that's a
different story
no no check it out this this this is
this is crazy I didn't know this
happened I left I left this area when I
was like 18 years old and what year was
that 2004 so yeah so around that time
actually they were doing they were
clearing the north side of Chicago okay
all low-income housing yeah I'm pushing
all those people to the south side
basically into these neighborhoods
around that let me talk let me tell you
what happened I'm talking to Lydia okay
I'm like check out this neighborhood and
I'm gonna be honest with you I have
never gone I've got on the same Road
one time when I was with some friends no
because we had been told you can't and I
mentioned this in the show before
because the police will stop you what
are you doing here you must be wanting
to buy drugs yeah you can't do that
and they might even like I was told if
you walk through the neighborhood you'll
either get into a conflict and you know
to in a manner of speaking with the
locals who are like what are you doing
or you'll end up with the police being
like yo get out and I had a friend who
was female who walked over and there was
an older black man saying honey turn
around you can't come in here
and it wasn't telling her like she had
to leave he was saying don't for your
protection protection like you don't
want to come in yeah so this is an area
they called LeClair courts okay
take a look at this image this is just
one image and so I was doing a google
google draw like you know Google Maps
from from last year and it was the
weirdest thing
and I'm looking at I'm like this doesn't
look at all like what I remember yeah
and so Lydia said why don't you go back
in time and so I went back to 2009 and I
was like oh there it is there it is wait
till you guys let me show you what look
for those that are watching you ready
for this let's jump let's jump to 2009
they raised every ten years later Wow
it's just about everything of grass is
gone this distance really blew my mind
and where are they where did all those
people go all those houses are gone look
at this let me let me jump back in time
again houses look at this sidewalks
houses power lines power lines dude you
know and then you come back today
Oh MD fields yeah the sidewalks from the
houses used to be still there look at
the street cones just where this alley
was between his houses wow I didn't know
I don't know they did this this is the
area where I grew up and they were like
this place is you know it's it's
low-income housing there's a lot of
crime and gang activity Chicago is
pretty strongly Democrat isn't it it's
it's been Democratic majority Democrat
this is conventions
yeah utopia this is what I think I you
know that's what I've been talking about
people
I have no perspective on Republicans
growing up in Chicago no none whatsoever
because for us we didn't care about
national level politics we cared about
can we get her skatepark build right and
you had the Democrats controlling
literally everything and so for me the
knife in the back always came from
Democrats not that I agreed with
Republican policy right I was you know
young lefty and the Democrats were the
ones who screwed everything up held us
back and they do policies like this now
look to be fair I don't know what they
do these people yeah but it's it's man
look at this empty field this is crazy
where's the plumbing what are they doing
where's the plumbing where's the power
lines yeah I don't care about any of
that where'd they put the people right
because when they did that to the north
side of Chicago and they pushed everyone
south they were gang worse Chicago
became the deadliest city in America for
a little while I don't remember which
years it was but it was
after they did all that and we got so
bad that the city told hospitals in
Chicago they're not allowed to accept
gunshot wounds so if you got shot in the
south side of Chicago you had to go to
any hospital outside of the state limits
which would take sometimes an hour there
was a kid who got was like a
seven-year-old kid got hit by it just a
random stray bullet are you serious and
they they went to the hospital and
they're like yeah but it was you know
it's a kid they got shot it was a sight
the hospital is like sorry we can't we
can't do it Wow you got to you got to
leave and go they had to drive like an
hour to the I don't remember what the
the next hospital up I mean it's insane
I'm over cities yeah and I think you
know so so for those that we do these a
separate segments res that are just
tuning in we were talking earlier about
how they do you know there's discussions
in minneapolis of disbanding the police
outright and we were saying we think
that the real issue is the cities have
become unlivable but isn't that why
world war one happened is because they
were all trying to consolidate power and
buy up all the land around Europe and
push everyone into cities as it was I'm
not exactly sure on this I have I think
I've had a few conversations with a
buddy mine's actually writing a
screenplay about World War Franz
Ferdinand the whole lead-up about what
happened and what led to World War one
so I know there was a lot of that going
on and all I can think is that anyone
who lives in a city is under someone
else's boot yeah and we need to get out
from under other people's boots it's not
a race issue it's a class issue being
stuck in someone else's butt under
someone else's boot you have to pay to
live anywhere you can't own property in
a city unless you got millions of
dollars you got who's got millions of
dollars just like buy their house at any
time they might just tell you to move
we're gonna raise your whole thing they
want you they want you renting they want
you buying food at their the grocery
stores around their you know living
basically on whatever they they want
like there's a sign right here what does
it say they're hyper property seriously
yeah not even a part time in a park what
is it yeah what is it that's go back in
time ready for this boom yeah this is
what I remember yeah and we were told
that
there's a lot of gang activity and you
don't you can't go in there well this
looks exactly like the place that I was
with so you know I was I was actually in
in kind of a gang when I was living in
Chicago I'm dead serious I'm not joking
around of kind of okay yes I was oh and
it was it was a place like this that we
got shot at and it was it was crazy it
was an intense one of the more intense
nights of my life
and kidding yeah it's like if you know
it's like it's not these people yeah I
wasn't blaming any of these people that
lived in these places it's the people
that put them there they forced their
hand and now they probably did it again
y'all have to leave we're raising this
we're gonna put a show it again a big
future grassfield
a big private property we're like what
are they what are they planning
it doesn't make no sense maybe you know
I think it's fair to say though there is
a possibility that low-income public
housing was a bad idea
yeah so I did I did a documentary on
Ferguson where we talked about
pruitt-igoe okay he was one of the first
public housing projects in history and
the idea was you have all these poor
people you give him a place to live you
can deal with homelessness and you can
maybe help them get on a better a better
footing yeah you know have raised their
kids get their kids you know better off
the problem was pruitt-igoe fell into
disrepair and it became a skyscraper
slum and then it was just it was just
just just awful just trash it's just you
know and so they they want to do good
but I think the problem is there's more
to teaching a man to fish than just
giving them a fishing around and walking
away yeah and that's one of the biggest
challenges that it seems like you know
what I refer to these Chinese finger
trap problems where it seems like you
know you gotta pull your fingers out but
it makes it worse yeah and you might
have do something counterintuitive and
maybe you know the first thing I'll say
is we clearly didn't have the answers no
I you know I I'll tell you there's gonna
be people from here who are gonna say
the city was evil for doing all this you
know and they're gonna be people say
this the city was evil for starting in
the first place and a big problem is
there's too many people that think they
know the answer
and their their answer is the correct
answer and that's never right because
works there so there's too many
different people out there for one
person to be like this is the way it
should be this is the answer this is
amazing every answer but maybe there is
we gotta get out of the cities yeah New
York New York is seeing a mass exodus
right now because of everything good man
think about what it must be like you
know there's a there's a New York Times
story published today about a jewelry
shop in Manhattan that's just been
ransacked completely yeah and there and
and they actually interview the person
saying like people are protesting in
front of my store but I can't even open
the door how does how does how does that
make sense yeah a thousand people walk
past my building I couldn't hand them
something that's the law these cities
are broken completely broken thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune into this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you